somebody told me a wonderful story which
you should know because you might you
know draw a comfort from it sky was very
pretty experienced he'd taken fairly
high doses of mushrooms before and he
took a six gram dose on a Saturday
evening in his apartment in LA and this
heart thing
began to develop that he identified as a
fibrillation or something so he tried to
cold it back and keep not know this and
not it kept getting stronger and strong
it never lets you do that by the way the
not noticing it's a paradox you didn't
take this to not notice so eventually he
becomes thoroughly alarmed and he tries
to call a couple of his friends well
it's Saturday night nobody's home so
then just this tremendous sense of
abandonment settles over this guy his
friends aren't there when he needs him
he's going to die here in his apartment
and be found days later so forth and so
on and he gets this ball rolling see so
finally he despairs he's a
psychotherapist an MD blah blah
everything he despairs he calls 911 they
get him they rush him to the hospital
they put him in a ward they any by the
time all this has happened and he's
gotten all this attention and probably a
little second all he's feeling pretty
good about it all so then he says to the
guy on duty he says I I feel like I have
to tell you I took psilocybin mushrooms
do you think that that brought this on
and the guy said no you had an anxiety
attack we get people with this all the
time I don't know anything about
psychedelic drugs so you know it isn't
the drug you have to worry about it's
yourself you have to discipline your
hindbrain you have to be able to say
listen shut up we're gonna come through
this just shut up about it because it's
saying but don't you think we should
call somebody we shouldn't treat it with
such levity because it is a serious
issue I mean I've been in many
circumstances where vital signs seem to
have fallen so low in my own perception
that I just was saying to myself keep
breathing keep looking keep breathing
keep looking and I felt you know that we
I was in a submarine five and a half
miles down easy does it through here
breath attention breath
attention because you have the feeling
that if you don't keep your attention on
your breath you will simply stop
breathing well now it's interesting
people who don't worry much about
psychedelics you tell them a story like
that and they say well isn't that the
bit that you take these drugs and you
think you
dying and then you get straight and then
you don't die and then you're really
happy isn't that what it's supposed to
do I thought that was what it was about
well in fact if you go back into the
literature in the 1960s the Tibetan Book
of the Dead crowd was saying you will be
flung from hell to paradise and back
again on about a 40-minute schedule for
several hours and they prepared
themselves for these bad trip situations
by anticipating it and I I don't release
think there's that much to it I think
your mind is very fragile in that state
and you know a bad thought quickly
becomes a cascade and you have to know
how to dis how to stock these cascades a
very practical technique that I use is I
take a hit of cannabis thinking you're
going to die at least for me is not all
that rare I mean if somebody invites me
to go sailing with them on the bay on a
Sunday afternoon at least twice in the
afternoon I will sign off completely and
just assume that's it
maybe I'm a little paranoid you know or
maybe I have crazy friends
[Music]
[Music]